absolutely the first decisive result of
the tournament a victory for magnus
carlson against his rival magnus welcome
to the show tell us a little bit about
this opening how did you choose it and
where did you think it was going to go
yeah i
decided to play something that's pretty
harmless but at least you get
some sort of you know typical position
that's generally
um
equal if like knows what he's doing um
but
i mean i thought it would be a decent
decent try um
and then yeah i
feel like uh it was was a massive uh
success uh eventually i eventually got
this
end game which um or queenless middle
game that is uh
that is not not much but it feels like a
massive success already to
to get this tell us a little bit about
your thought process in this position
you have the double pawns on the queen
side and certainly that's going to be no
i i feel like more about what uh about
what happened later because at this
point i still felt like maybe he could
have played a bit more more
concretely but
yeah i know i i don't know also
i i really don't like the double g pawns
for for him it feels like right as long
as he cannot get
anything going there soon there could be
a target in the in the future as you saw
in the in the game his pawn structure
became
pretty mobile and also um
and also a bit weak uh towards the end
but yeah i just felt that i have the two
bishops of course it's unbelievably
solid but it's a position to
to play and i didn't know if it would
particularly suit him either so i i was
pretty happy um i was thinking thinking
quite a bit over the next few months
because there are so many
there are so many possibilities um on
each move there but
um
so many so many plans and it's not clear
if any of them actually did anywhere um
what do you think he went wrong i think
he made a number of uh inaccuracies um
starting where uh so
uh i didn't like the
first of all i'm not sure i liked the a6
from him a6 on move 18 i'm with 18 yes
this particular i think it was okay but
i was wondering like if conceptually if
if a5 was more challenging here just to
keep the bishop on b4 and the queen side
this could be a weakness eventually but
i just didn't see how to
to exploit it and otherwise i'm sort of
shuffling and not doing not doing all
that much and
that's why i also made this move bishop
f2 and move 20. i mean first of all i
thought it was useful just to anticipate
bishop d66 because rook d8 really
indicated this bishop um yeah so
um
after bishop d6 also i spent a lot of
time on bishop d3 i just
um it was really hard for him to find a
a move here um rookie eight you could
play but it's not clear if the rook is
is can we start with c5 here
c5 is peter's question in this position
uh g5
just wins yeah well yeah with the [ __ ]
one six we can't at all yeah yeah okay
yeah so i guess not in this position
yes yeah
i don't know maybe he had it in some
other positions but it wasn't it wasn't
obvious yeah according to you what do
you think black should be aiming for in
this position
uh wait and
and try and prevent my plans i don't
think he can do anything actively right
like if i don't play poorly i don't
think he'll be able to play
c5 under decent circumstances so he
should mainly wait and wait and see
which is not always a pleasant
proposition especially not for a dynamic
player like jane pomney and the engines
were actually considering to even just
hide the king on beat as their way of
waiting for white to do something did
you feel that after yeah it wasn't
obvious that the king was well placed in
e7 yeah at all no
so uh bishop b8 uh the engines thought
this was actually a big mistake i know i
really really really was happy to see
that as well
[Music]
because i'd seen this knight a4 bish b1
uh yes i've hear knight a4 bishop d6
bishop b1 trying to get before yeah as
soon as i get b4 that's a huge strategic
achievement then i think we can talk
about something a little bit more
tangible so
i
was sure he was going to go for c5
but that leads i think more or less by
force to the position that we got i mean
first of all knight c7 was monumentally
stupid
uh because it gave him the chance to go
bishop c5 and then d4 i mean i assume
it's really bad
where when when he played c5 knight c5
knight c5 in this position uh takes and
then d4
um
yeah i mean in general it just doesn't
no no no
bishop c5 ah bishop c5 in this position
yeah because i could have gone dc5 and
ryan doesn't have a choice you can go
bishop c5s
d
dc5 and then
uh and then d4 but i assume that he has
way too few squares here and that in
general white is much better but he it
was
he was not very uh very professional
anyway after what he did yes we get this
position
moral no i i think we get
what happened more or less about force i
mean he could computer indicates 97 for
some reason i didn't see what he'd do in
this position yeah i didn't see what
he'd do and then in case of bishop c3
yes
um but yeah okay king favorite very
super ugly that's super ugly i agree um
yeah anyway i thought this was more or
less forced b5 e5
uh sorry a5 that's one we were surprised
by a5 they don't expect i expected that
100 percent high five times 85
disposition but this is
it's it's i mean nothing is happening at
the moment is but it's really unpleasant
that my my extra pawn is
kind of meaningful because i can
um
because they cover a few extra squares
like if you remove the pawn from b2 then
there's no question of me being being
better but
right here they cover they cover some
some squares obviously if i give one of
them away and
and i have um he has a couple of
weaknesses both on f7 and on d5 and my
bishop is a better bit better than his
knights yeah eventually
i think the game proceeded pretty
um
uh logically there rookie seven yeah
that wasn't that wasn't ideal but uh
it was logical at least and then it
didn't seem like he put up a lot of
personnel i mean especially king c7 that
was just resigns on the spot right like
he has to go for this rook ending but
it's it's truly terrible yeah to be fair
the engine was already giving you plus
five here at least the super range of
the yeah i mean also knight c5 i think
was conceptually
wrong you should have put it on b6 and
it's it's a really horrible position
i'll double the rooks on the on the uh d
file eventually i put i'll push e4 and
once we trade my bishop will be very
strong and f7 and b7 will both be weak
but at least there was a way to
uh to fight after what he did bishop b5
he could have
resigned with uh with a clear conscience
that's very true magnus it seemed like a
very smooth sailing after you got this
queenless middle game he didn't wasn't
able to maneuver as well as you did and
he kind of fell apart do you feel like
this are a little bit ghost of what
happened in dubai
no i didn't get a lot of these kinds of
games there so um
i don't know he didn't do so well in the
in the rapid either so probably
i mean this was just
a game of somebody who's not in
not in great shape was not finding
he was not finding the right maneuvers
overlooking
[Music]
um overlooking
some of my ideas also he was playing too
fast i mean
at critical moments
didn't really sense them too much so i
think i did well in creating a situation
that was not pleasant for him but yeah
certainly should have done better well
definitely that's not the shape of a man
that can hold the game against you
especially with the black pieces
congratulations on your starting with a
win here at the singfield cup and good
luck with the rest of your games thank
you our congratulations as well magnus a
very very fine effort in